regarding screenwriting wondering if you
can talk about the power of intention
and how a writer needs to check their
own intention either during the writing
of it before the writing of it afterward
sure so we're all a bunch of humans
running around okay and on some level we
are all pretty much the same right
biologically whatever however what
really separates us is our experiences
and our perspectives because everyone
although similar you know American
culture is similar let's say we're
growing up in a city or growing up in
suburbs or you know these kinds of
things what you've experienced through
your life and what you're interested in
and what you're educated in and things
like that that is what really gives you
your voice right so if you can tap in to
what matters to you and understand why
it matters to you then you can write
with power not only from your head and
your imagination but from your heart if
what you're writing doesn't matter to
you it's going to be flat it's never
really going to in mode but if you can
tap in and understand what your gifts
are what your perspective is what you
believe then you can create characters
and stories based around that
fictionalize it you know embellish it or
whatever however you do it dramatize it
and then create within a narrative
structure you know as a screenplay and
that is where great screenplays come
from with someone really know write and
spend time on something that didn't
matter yes it happens okay I think I
think people do I think I think people
chase trends you know oh I don't know
romantic comedies are big this year
looks bright romantic comedies okay like
is that really coming from what you're
passionate about maybe but maybe not
often I also think screenwriters don't
dig in deep enough to really understand
where they're coming from the pain and
the and the triumph that drives these
stories so continually digging deeper
asking yourself why are you doing this
why do you care about these characters
for instance one of my screenplays is
called panaceas dream it's about a
shaman and a scientist to develop this
pill that heals anybody and I'm making a
fortune off this thing and it works but
they don't know why it works the science
driving the scientist crazy and the
shaman takes it on faith it's the power
of faith in this pill so this is a huge
expression for me because part of me is
like I'm a scientist I'm skeptical I
want to know you know where things are
coming from in the world and the other
part believes that this is a magical
world where the metaphysics and the
mysteries are everywhere right
both of these are within me and then
both of them are in flux gameplay right
so by digging into these kinds of
questions these kinds of truths these
kinds of subjects a screenwriter can get
a lot deeper into what they believe and
then express it why do you think that
they haven't dug deep are they just not
that self-aware I don't know I mean
there's all kinds of screenwriters some
are going to be completely self-aware
some are going to be completely clueless
you know just like people you know but I
guess I'm just suggesting that as you're
considering what to write these kinds of
questions can really inform
to activate and engage your stories and
your characters if they matter to you
they will matter to somebody else and if
they don't and I just won't
you